and tonight they'll get daniel lynch for
the third time this year yeah lynch you
know they'll do the same thing they'll
try to come out and ambush that fastball
you had a live drive base hit right
field for miles strong
weak chopper to second the only play
from merrifield is at first and he was
lucky to get rosario one down
runner goes to third perez's throw
forget about it
miles straw with his 29th stolen base on
the year
yep in the air deep center back is
taylor
he will make the catch
jose ramirez will get his 100th run
batted in on the year
mile straw comes home to score and the
indians have a one-nothing lead well
zach please please sack will be the
indian starting pitcher police act 10-6
on the year he is 7-4 on the road coming
off a start against chicago he pitched
well had a no decision but he has
pitched very well in his career against
the royals this year 1-0 with a 2 45
earned run average the royals are due to
get him there you go
that will be cut off deep by harold
ramirez but here comes wit on his way to
second yes and he is in there
he hit another gear
in between first and second base
and he will take ball four
coming back from one and two and that
puts two on with nobody out for salvi
the anticipation now for his home run
begins before
mike mccartney announces him at kauffman
stadium
and he hits it to center field
deep and gone
a three-run
record-tying home run for salvador perez
and how many times
has he answered the ovation
that is home run number 48. the crowd
wants a curtain call why wouldn't he
and one more and the record
appropriately will begin to belong to
him
taylor now stumbled
but so did ramirez in left field and
michael is going to end up with a double
and now he
goes limping into second base
[Applause]
back to the middle and kyle isbell is
going to drive in michael a taylor
and the royals lead 4-1 in the second
inning
good
[Applause]
deep enough
very deep and ramirez never looked
comfortable
so what's going to have another double
and the royals are going to get another
run
ramirez gave it a good run but
just kind of drifted back he didn't
really get back until the last minute
there
if you don't think
salvador perez
is super human already
after being helped down the stairs
just a few moments ago
by two
members of the royals coaching staff
[Applause]
he is standing in the on deck circle
[Applause]
foul tip
and a strikeout
and maybe just a slight hint of a limp
so salvi was okay for another at-bat but
not okay to
crouch down behind home plate for the
rest of the game so cam gallagher will
take over now watch salvi going down the
stairs of the dugout this is after the
top of the second inning the double play
fine fine and then right here
that's where he fell down the stairs at
the very end
from there we saw him being helped
down the next set of stairs leading to
the royals clubhouse
where maybe he got his ankle taped up
and
as tough as he is wanted to get back out
there and play and after taking a few
swings
that was the end of his night yeah
ground ball base it down the right field
line that'll get a run home hedges score
nice oscar mercado coming into third he
gets stopped there stop today
and then the second with an rbi doubles
rosario his 25th double of the year so
much like the third inning the first two
batters will reach
right back at him and it hit him i think
yes and it goes into center field around
third scoring is chang on his way to
third is miller indians at the corners
and that's got to be it for daniel lynch
it's a 5-3 ball game
he chops it to third and the royals are
unable to turn the double play a run
will score
and mile straw is down in first with two
down
hey there you go gonna be an infield hit
for fran mill race
see if maybe next year he can lead the
league in infield hit no
we got two other guys that can do that
the one two swung on ripped past the
shortstop into left field at bay set
and the indians have something brewing
here in the fifth inning
down the line it's a fair ball
here comes the tying run as euchang
scores into third harold ramirez will
stop there it's an rbi double for eu
chang
and it's a five five ball game here in
k.c
[Applause]
there's a base hitting to right center
gallagher turns and holds and now it
gets by mercado
straw
was
coming over from center and backed him
up
pitched to dozier and he's hit by the
pitch so that'll load the bases 2-2 to
taylor
swing and a miss he struck him out to
get out of the inning and leave the
bases loaded they've got two on with two
out in the seventh dozer oh for two
and dozier hits it to right field deep
back goes mercado it is off the wall
and with two outs the runners were going
the royals will get two and dozier is in
the third
triple for dozier the royals lead it
seven to five
well now the ball gets away from the
catcher and dozier's gonna score the
royals eighth run they go up by three
is bell is running and alberto shoots
one to the gap
that will be down
and it will bounce off the top of the
wall
allowing
isbell to score from first
and hanser alberto
hits the ball hard to the outfield for a
third time tonight but that's his first
hit and the royals lead 9-5 in the
eighth
alberto at third and a line drive into
left field and gallagher having quite a
night
it is ten to five
that's gonna be a catch by nikki lopez
to end the game so the royals have
clinched the series
and the royals franchise
has won 4 000 games right on the button